he's with Fox Sports 1 right and I don't
even know who you were then II more
mancation with everybody pac-12 network
you got your own Sirius XM pac-12 radio
channel 737 373 Monday through Friday
and a great host I shall say you did a
great job filling in right here in this
chair Ryan Leaf thanks for coming back
on the show bud thank you really
grateful for the opportunity Wow was I
didn't I couldn't believe the the amount
of support and outreach that came with
it which I sent you a few things Ryan
I'm telling you the video with you
coming here I mean obviously being
yourself is the the most crucial aspect
of broadcasting and where people say you
know what that person that guy that that
girl that lady that guy is real and and
you just came on you're like hey this is
who I am this is where I've been this is
where I want to go let's all hang out
for the next three hours
that's why literally over half million
people share ya know five hundred and
twenty thousand and that's just on
Twitter alone yeah so wait way to go
nice girl she told them when I when I
got out here I said this I wanted this
to feel like I was sitting at the
breakfast tables my dad talking sports
right and it's and Chris was big for
that I can look over at him like I just
and it was that I did forgot that it was
TV I almost actually forgot that was
radio and I just kind of yeah I mean
some people will come here and drop
f-bombs that they're just chilling and
relaxing and so you were great at it
great at it and and so I know you're
you're continuing on in your career
let's start with what you told me back
in our green room here about who has
reached out to you and say hey let's
let's work together
yeah you and I are gues colleagues now
right okay uh rich works for the works
for the NFL the NFL Network and the NFL
just hired me Oh two weeks ago to
I'm one of the program coordinators for
the NFL Legends community which is
essentially helping players with their
transition from the NFL to real life
because it's it's so difficult very
similar to what Jay Glazer and they Nate
Boyer do with MVP with vets and players
because that transition is is so
difficult you go from being on top of
this pedestal to really your career
being over and then what's next your
identity no matter if you played twenty
years
or really one or two years you really
don't know what that identity is you
have to have have help figuring it out
and we're there to be a fellowship and I
I didn't think I was a legend that's the
way I interpreted it and I walked into
one of those lounges at the Super Bowl
back in San Francisco and Chad
Pennington was there and Warrick Dunn
Donnie Edwards all former teammates
friends of mine that just put their arm
around me and said you know what we were
able to do to get where we got that
makes us NFL legends regardless of what
anybody else thinks and the fact that
you know four years removed from going
into that room tracey Perlman and in the
NFL and mr. Goodell have asked me to to
represent them I mean that's feuded told
me that four and a half years ago when I
walked out of a prison cell that I'll be
working for the NFL or even that I'd
want to be around the NFL that those are
miracles well cuz again having been
around the league is obviously as I have
been and I knowing the Commissioner as I
do and the program as well what what
also is making you a legend is what you
have done in the last four and a half
years because what the league wants to
do is tell all these kids who come off
of campuses like Washington state with
the resumes like you had there's a lot
of big men on campus who are about to be
drafted fourth fifth sixth round or not
at all
we're gonna be wondering what the hell
just happened or they are drafted top
five in the draft and three and a half
years later because that's the average
length of an NFL career they've got to
find something else to do and they might
find that a very difficult transition
and you being able to be there right
there every step of the way that is
invaluable that is legendary stuff Ryan
I appreciate that that's fact I went to
the summit we had our summit in
Fort Lauderdale a week ago and I got to
be around all my my new brothers in the
NFL Brotherhood and it I didn't feel
when I walked into that room like I like
less than or judged or anything like
that I don't feel that anymore and they
make it feel welcoming and I know that I
have a purpose and that's all what it's
about
when a player retires or a player gets
through the other factor they find
another purpose right and and and I
really feel like I found that and I'm
really grateful for the opportunity
that's great so are you gonna be some
because the legends are from the legends
community are on the field at the
combine talking to the kids talking to
the prospects in the meeting room stuff
is that the sort of stuff you're gonna
do I got the opportunity to do it two
years ago when it was the deshaun Watson
Patrick mahomes group Mitchell true
Biscay they were in my group and you
know you really could tell the guys that
were I walked in the room and told them
well you have Mark Brunell stand up and
say I played 19 years in the NFL and I
stand up when I go four years in the NFL
and and it almost says I almost feel
shameful a little bit when I do it in
the room with Tony Richardson and Mark
Brunell and they they play that long but
we know but Ryan you're your NFL
experience is is the average and NFL
Express well I mean it's average in
terms of length but all the other
aspects of yours is unique and if
somebody could be told in real time if
somebody could have told you in real
time now you might have been so messed
up that you wouldn't listen to anybody
but I mean I guess I've heard many
situations like that and I don't want to
speak for you but if you could be there
in real time for somebody three we even
three weeks from now cuz this stuff can
hit you fast is an NFL rookie really
really fast so that's invaluable stuff
and it was it was really interesting to
see the guys who stepped up in a
leadership position in within a
leadership group of quarterbacks patch
from the homes was one of the biggest
guys that asked a bunch of questions to
me about things and I mean you could
just tell some of the guys that they
were they were gonna step up and do that
Nathan Peterman was was probably one of
them the most knowledgeable and
fundamental and technical quarterbacks
it hasn't translated so much into the
NFL but there was a reason why he ended
up in Buffalo because of what he did
that process Ryan leave here on the
riches Joe what do you think of the kids
in this year's class right now it's Mari
and then a couple of questions right now
if Haskins is before lock lock before
Haskins could daniel Jones of Duke
surprise some people be by being the
second quarterback off the board where
do you where do you say well I think
it's it's it's alone right now with
Kyler Murray I mean the the visit to
Arizona last week I heard that there was
even talk of you know started
negotiating a contract which they can do
because they're the first pick in the
NFL Draft right the question is is by
doing all this and letting people know
about that they really lose their
leverage on what they're gonna do with
Josh Rosen because they can't carry two
first-round draft picks that quarterback
just cap wise and what it would do
inside the locker room I think well I
mean plus you need to have the the the
one thing the reason why I don't think
they could they can do it is there needs
to be somebody who's been there done
that for Kyler Murray right now you
can't just have two guys who are kind of
figuring it out together at the same
time you're gonna have a veteran
presence to beat not that Murray can't
figure it out himself but you do need to
have that some somebody there who's done
it six seven eight maybe even more years
than that to talk when I was in San
Diego was they were gonna possibly bring
in Warren Moon he had been for you yes
he had been under Kevin Gilbride in
Houston right and would be there instead
they decided to go with just two
quarterbacks on the roster me and a
young man named Craig we Lahan who
hadn't really played or would play and
we were just kind of a room full of
misfits of not really not knowing what
was gonna happen or when things went bad
so that's that's a huge factor there's
been rumblings around the idea of of the
Washington team maybe making a trade III
would think that if they if the
Cardinals are trying to make something
work they're maybe try to trade back for
Case Keenum yeah we're here I mean I'm
hearing that too that's just is that
that's a lot of player movement it's a
lot of players move to go from Denver to
Arizona right or to Washington and then
the funny thing is they both have the
same agent Kyler Murray and Case Keenum
have have the same agent Kingsbury yeah
it's it's becoming incestuous a little
bit that's the way job that's the way
deals do get
Don it is do you think that's a good fit
for Rosen in Washington uh-huh I think I
think it would be great if he ended up
in New York I don't know how it's gonna
play out the leverage isn't there for
them to leverage any other team to get a
first round draft pick maybe not even a
second I know that the Giants have a
solid third-round pick that probably
could work I hope they do something like
that because then they can use the sixth
pick in the 17th for defensive lineman
and offensive lineman really build
something and they would get the
quarterback to they probably should have
drafted a year ago not taking anything
away from sake one-car see what he did
but you know quarterbacks franchise
quarterbacks move this league if they
could do that that'd be huge it would be
an ultimate win for the New York Giants
I just don't know if it's gonna be able
to get done some teams gonna panic the
last minute probably offer up a bigger
draft pick to the Cardinals to get the
quarterback because they need one I know
the Dolphins are in need down there
Washington like you talked about the big
question mark I have is Dwayne Haskins I
don't see how what he's done not only
last year but all the way through the
draft process that doesn't put him at
the top of the draft and what I hear is
he just keeps sliding backward and
backward and backward it there's
something that we're not we're not
hearing otherwise I don't know why this
would be the case I don't understand it
because he's good people
yeah he's also a guy who's 50 touchdowns
in the big 10 yeah I mean and he was he
got better and better and better he's
he's physically he fits the role one
would think of a bigger guy Jameis
Winston sighs in kind of it's not
necessarily you know he's not gonna win
any you know muscle magazine awards but
he's he's gonna get out there and stand
in the pocket take hits and make throws
down the football field which he did and
he led teams back if it wasn't for him
last year they wouldn't even have been
in the conversation for the college
football playoff they would have lost
the Penn State game Maryland they would
have lost the Maryland game for sure so
those two right there alone tell you
what Dwayne Haskins and how important he
was to that team they were to lost the
Michigan game too right Chris probably
not that one huh come on man probably
not he's by the way I need to every now
and then if you don't mind make sure
they're not watching the Masters as
opposed to listening to us
right Chris Zach Johnson just hittin em
oh my god I think we're having a
terrific conversation what no copy so
let's talk a little bit about every
other things that you're up to right now
you're producing this show called busts
right where's this winding up as it's
been picked up has it been bought worth
yet we had some good meetings in New
York a week ago um a docu-series about
us it's really important I just like
Google Alerts came up on our computer
and and the biggest headlines the Google
Alerts today for my name is I was on top
of the hundred biggest draft bots draft
bust by USA Today so every April this is
what what happens and the understanding
of what the expectations are and those
who made it made it through mm-hmm
untethered and came out the other end I
want to hear from those guys I want to
hear how they did it
you know how they and I want to hear
from the guys that are still struggling
now so who are the other guys that
you're you're targeting well I think
Matt liner is a perfect example right he
when you when you talk about Matt he's
one of the greatest college quarterbacks
to ever play people really don't talk
about his NFL career because he really
found it he was at peace with he took
away the power from and he got into
broadcasting really in the college
football realm he's really made a great
name for himself and he's a solid
individual i I've spent a lot of time
with him I think he's a perfect example
to help teach individuals how to deal
with that or in my case I just let it
burn me to the ground and I followed and
there have been guys like that and
there's still guys that are in that
right now they're they're living in that
identity and I thought it would be very
interesting to hear their their their
view and also I want to help them like
if they're in a place where they're
still struggling just like the NFL
legends or the MVP program we want to
help them take the power away of that
word bus it's it's it's a small short
walk from bus in a Pro Football Hall of
Fame to bus as a draft pick I mean
they're the same word right completely
different so yeah a lot of interest from
people the funny thing is I'm going to
be the one in conducting the interviews
and I think that makes it important it's
the biggest selling point is because no
one else
can get the same information or no one
can call somebody else on their crap
other than me because I did exactly the
same thing or was in declan's like like
if somebody I'm talking to and I say
didn't it just didn't it just absolutely
kill you to walk off the field and have
you know ten thousand people yelling at
you that you suck or when you walk down
the street mm-hmm somebody just you know
offshoot hundred yards behind bust hmm I
mean it has to affect you so much
internally and don't tell me you're
strong enough to deal with it I wasn't I
mean it buried me in the idea that I was
a failure and uh and into depression to
a point where I ended up in a prison
cell because I had to self medicate and
um that all away so I want to I think
it's a very interesting concept and I
want and I hope that when we get through
it all
each and every one of them who may still
be struggling that powers away and they
find this peaceful on chaotic life that
I felt and a big part of that you know I
wanted to talk to you yeah about what
this show did for me right people
reached out they watched that first
15-minute segment just talked about when
you filled in here yeah the
accountability part of it and they've
reached out and asked for help and
that's that's almost like the platform
it would be like that's amazing and now
it hasn't been easy right because I have
the ability to call him on their stuff
like yesterday I'm working with an
individual reached out and asked for
help and like the last emoji or the last
text message I got from almost like you
know triple-barreled middle finger
emojis to me after I was calling them on
on some of his stuff but then I heard
last night he got into a detox center
and his sober for the first time in 15
years or something like that and not
only that I've had people reach out who
were going into broadcasting and I'm
like how what made you just how could
you do this cuz four and a half years
ago if I just walked up to you and said
Richard what about me hosting your show
I mean I'm pretty sure you would looked
at me like what yeah yeah yeah where
does that start where does that get to
and your show the platform is allowed
for has done amazing things just in the
two-and-a-half weeks you've been back
that's awesome in here
thanks I'm thrilled but again like just
to put a button on it and then we'll
take a break we'll come back we'll have
some Game of Thrones fun it's when you
were texting me or DMing me or how we
were communicating after you did the
show and you're like hey
the you coming on I'm like it's what you
did with the opportunity so I didn't do
anything
I just said you know what that sounds
great I think you'll be great you know i
I've gotten to know you I've seen your
your work I've seen you come on the show
I've seen you on other shows that's all
good
you know but it's what you did when you
sat in the show I didn't you know I
didn't tell you you should come on here
and you should bare your soul Ryan as a
man or or you met you you can't do it
without baring your soul that was your
choice that was your decision that was
your execution of it that was your
broadcasting style that was you you did
it so I just gave you the Chairman oh
thank you for the opportunity let me
have it back only half million people
don't you know watched your hey-oh
you know people go to the freak show all
the time sometimes they just come to
watch you push the red button down and
self-employed it's all right everybody
Rockford is looking to be like how can
you make that him saying that he's a
musician huh I listen to music oh let's
take a break I know your big game of
Thrones nut your big Game of Thrones fan
we have a list here of 10 characters
that we are going to have a snake draft
Chris Brockman won the putting contest
you're first i'm second del two foes
third true flat out survivor pool who's
gonna last Lou's lasting long as like
Tyler Murray situation my first pick
should already be known I know it is as
well he's yes he's portrayed him in uh
in Halloween okay eight four four two oh
four rich number to dial that's next
year on the Rich Eisen show while we
keep an eye or some of us on the masters
AT&T delivers the best way to watch all
the action at this year's Masters on
DirecTV now through Sunday channel 701
through 7:05 four full channels of
coverage throughout the tournament to 4k
channels devoted to feature holes Amen
Corner 15 16 to order DirecTV call one
eight hundred DirecTV Brooks koepka
stepping all over himself this morning
and that's the only way to put it
he's 4-under three back Bryson to Shambo
two back to Shambo bogeyed said oh my
gosh Phil alone in second place the long
in second place 5-under front Cheska
Molinari
who also sounds like I think one of
those cars from cars - he's my appease
my pick Francesco Molinari sound right
Ryan we feel okay he's tied with Jason
Dan Brooks koepka there we go
greatest Sunday ever you know what we
were talking about that it's tough to
beat a Super Sunday Shaun McVeigh Rams
head coach here on the show coming up at
our number two it's tough to beat
what championship Sunday Derby Saturday
like but again we're talking about a
master's championship the green jacket
being slipped on and then one of the
most iconic television shows the 21st
century coming back for a finale that
the whole world is literally waiting I
think it's the last great show we're all
sharing together at once right because
everything else it's not a reality
competition series we're supposed to
hang by the mask or somebody's singing
behind a chair or so many ray I'm just
saying this is a real shared experience
between Bertie vision all of us have a
TV showing it going forward it's either
a streaming service you're just kind of
watching whatever right other than the
Rich Eisen show right I mean I've no
idea how many people are settling around
couches right now and telling children
shush Rich's about rich is about to
choose Game of Thrones characters with
Mike dill to phone Chris Brockman Ryan
Leaf Singh - they're sitting in the
middle of homeland it's all happening
I mean I'd literally just pulled the
conversation out of American ether right
there all right so we have here 10
character names there are very very
popular big names here Ryan you're gonna
help the process if anybody needs a
phone a friend situation good Ryan's
gonna comment hope you can provide some
comments about that I knew all the
informations was gonna be given out one
day so basically we've got a list of 10
characters we're about to have a draft
who's going to last the longest and if
they last long if they last through
episode 1 that's one point okay episode
two that's two points
episode three three points and the adds
up like the NCAA tournament
okay I like it all the way through
there's six episodes correct next we
want to do a bonus for winning the I
guess it's six points for surviving
episode 6 - right if you win if you win
the whole thing if they win yeah I guess
that's the way we got to do it bonus all
right so the characters are the night
King Queen Cersei Arya Stark Samwell
Tarly Sansa Stark Tyrion Lannister bran
Stark Jaime Lannister the Kingslayer Jon
Snow and Khaleesi the mother of dragons
Daenerys Targaryen those are the ten
characters you can't name any bigger
characters right here in this cell
Charlie mix okay so exact brockman you
you you have the first overall selection
we have four minutes to complete this
year on the class the first overall pick
this whole series is about him he will
win at the end Jon Snow Jon Snow I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go with I think
everybody thinks he's gonna win it
because he's what putting his mind in
the Ravens and he can control dragons
and he's I'm gonna do bran Stark
alright I think King would you like that
one I like that one I think that him
falling off the roof or getting pushed
off the tower in the first episode to
him being the the guy on the Iron Throne
at the end or just seer of all at the
end
by the way by the way if it's winds up
that he's been dead all along I don't
that doesn't count against me I don't
hear when he fell off the go flat
Michael making night king then you go
you got once again that's why I'm going
tonight do you think he's gonna like
he's good and you know he's gonna last
every episode so not a bad one Targaryen
Mike you're taking Daenerys yeah okay
okay so the night King's off the board
and Daenerys off the board Snow's off
the board I took brand I'm gonna take
Tyrion Lannister oh nice I like my team
right now what do you think I like your
pants darken Tyrion Lannister I like my
team I just want and I hope that the
producers and the riders have kept
tearing around for the entire so I don't
want to be cheated out of Tyrion
Lannister on the last season he is every
scene that he is in Peter Dinklage is
phenomenal okay Brock when you grant
you've got to now here's this next guy
is in no way shape or form gonna be on
any type of battlefield so I can't see
him dying at all
Samwell Tarly that's a good one oh and
also I'm gonna take the queen of
Winterfell Sansa Stark okay
now I go huh rich your last pick I think
all the Lannisters are eating it and
everybody thinks Arya Stark is gonna eat
it too why why do people think Arya's
because she's just she's got too big for
us to be like her dad right making the
wrong moves and paying for it
finish her list nonetheless I'm taking
her I'm telling the other Lannister that
right there
solidified your team it's it's sewn up
right now okay
they'll to go last pick all right so you
have Searcy or Jaime left
seriously okay Jaime Lannister left on
the board the Kingslayer yeah I think
he's gonna go to full you have a badass
team so del Toro's team is the night
King Queen Cersei Daenerys and Khaleesi
she's got both Queens nice Delta
Brockman's team
is John snow yeah and then you went back
then you went back to back with Sam
Carly Sam Carly and sanso Kahn says he's
gonna last and I go with bran Tyrion and
Arya Stark yes six winning I don't know
the most points that's tough I think
you're going to win thank you right I do
think that Arya Stark is this this this
show has turned into a a female-driven
show and I believe a female character is
going to be on top when it's all said
all I know is that if Arya Stark is
there as the hand to Brian with tyrion
lannister raising a glass after they
whip thing I think we all win
no I win oh gee by 3 that's a three for
three right I think we all win though I
think you think we all win because good
to see you Ryan Leaf good to see ya Ryan
D leaf on Twitter and Instagram Congrats
in the NFL Kate thank you sir
four more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app